je suis si d'aullène papaya âgé de 44
ans est conseillère départementale dans
le canton 6
je suis attaché à ce canton parce que
mes parents ayant vécu je suis moi-même
né j'ai grandi je vis j'ai travaillé
aussi et mener des actions sur ce beau
territoire donc forcément j'y suis
attaché également c'est un canton qui
est tourné vers la ruralité et c'est un
sujet qui me porte à coeur
jean de compétence du département sont
très larges mais nous allons nous
focaliser dans un premier temps sur
les personnes âgées nous souhaiterions
ouvrir une structure d'accueil est
également deuxième domaine dans
l'agriculture nous voulons soutenir
défendre et accompagner nos agriculteurs
et nos éleveurs de ce canton et soutenir
la diversification agricole
c'est vrai que de parme profession j'ai
pu être proche de la population
notamment dans tous les écarts du siècle
de salazie et j'ai pu voir et comprendre
les difficultés maintenant si le
département peut permettre à ce que nous
prenions soin d'un territoire et de sa
population
je veux m'y engager